>> COMING UP, ROLL UP ON THIS
CLOWN AND PUNCH DOWN, LIKE OUT,
SON!
>> THAT'S COLD, BRO.
>> YEAH, 119 IS MY BLOCK.
THAT'S JUST HOW IT IS.
WHOO!
>> HEY.
>> LET'S GO SIT DOWN OVER HERE
YOUNG BLOOD.
YOU KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THIS
GAME?
>> YEAH, I'VE PLAYED A COUPLE
TIMES.
>> AH, YOU DON'T PLAY CHESS,
YOUNG BLOOD.
'CAUSE THIS AIN'T NO GAME.
IT'S A ROAD MAP TO NAVIGATIN'
THESE STREETS.
>> WHAT YOU TALKING ABOUT OLD
MAN?
>> WHAT I MEAN, YOUNG BLOOD, IS
YOU OUT HERE ACTING LIKE A PAWN,
YOU SEE?
YOU'RE RUNNING YOUR MOUTH,
YOU'RE SWINGING YOUR FISTS.
PAWNS IS ALL ABOUT THAT BATTLE.
BUT YOU WANT TO BE THE KING, YOU
GOT TO BE THINKING ABOUT THE
WAR, YOU FEEL ME?
>> YEAH, BUT A PAWN CAN DO SOME
DAMAGE.
SO --
>> SURE.
YEAH.
AND YOU KNOW, EVERY KING IS
GOING TO LOSE A FEW PAWNS WHEN
YOU'RE TRYING TO WIN THAT WAR,
RIGHT?
BUT IT AIN'T ABOUT WHAT YOU
LOSE, YOUNG BLOOD.
>> CHECK MATE.
>> NO.
>> [ INAUDIBLE ] I'M GOING TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU SEE THE THING ABOUT THE
KING, YOUNG BLOOD IS, HE'S A
HARD BROTHER TO KILL.
LOOK, HE'S BACK IN THE GAME.
>> YO, I DON'T THINK THOSE ARE
THE RULES OF THE GAME, MAN.
>> THEY'RE THE RULES OF THE
STREETS!
NOW THE KING, SOMETIMES, GOES ON
THE ATTACK.
RIGHT.
BUT THEN SOME TIMES.
>> CHECK MATE.
>> SOME TIMES THERE ARE TWO
KINGS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> COME ON, MAN.
>> AND THEN YOU KNOW EVERY KING,
NEEDS HIMSELF A CASTLE.
>> THAT'S A BISHOP, FOOL.
>> I KNOW THAT.
>> OH, YOU DO, HUH?
OKAY.
WHAT'S THIS ONE CALLED?
>> THAT'S HORSEY.
>> YOU MEAN THE KNIGHT?
>> THE KNIGHT.
NOW GO SIT YOUR ASS DOWN
SOMEWHERE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING
ANYWAY.
>> ANYWAY.
NOW THIS -- THIS A CASTLE.
NOW YOU SEE, YOUR CASTLE IS YOUR
HITTER, RIGHT?
AND IF THIS CASTLE, SEES SOME OF
THEM PAWNS COMING AT YOU.
HE'S GOING TO DO --
OH, NOW WHY DID I DO THAT?
>> YOU WANT A DO-OVER ON THAT
MOVE?
>> OH, YOU JUST FELL FOR THE
OLDEST TRICK IN THE BOOK, YOUNG
BLOOD.
>> NO HE DIDN'T.
>> SHUT UP.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SEE I GOT YOU THINKING, THAT I
MADE A MISTAKE.
BUT WHAT I'M REALLY DOING IS --
>> CHECK MATE.
>> YEAH, YEAH, BUT KINGS CAN
JUMP.
>> WHAT?
YO, I'M HAVING TROUBLE FOLLOWING
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
>> THAT'S BECAUSE HE IS TALKING
A LOAD OF [ BLEEP ].
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> LOOK HERE, YOUNG BLOOD.
YOU SHOULD REALLY LEARN THE
LESSONS OF THIS EXCITING NEW
GAME.
>> NEW GAME.
>> BECAUSE IF NOT -- MAN, YOU
GONNA GET PLAYED.
LOOK AT THAT.
I JUST -- I WON EVERYTHING.
I JUST WON EVERYTHING.
>> ALL RIGHT, OLD MAN.
I GUESS I'LL KEEP THAT IN MIND.
>> COOL.
>> $20.
>> EXCUSE ME, WHAT?
>> $20 FOR MY TIME?
>> THANK YOU, YOUNG BLOOD.
THANK YOU.
>> MAN, LET'S GET OUT OF HERE,
GUYS.
>> COOL.
>> ALL RIGHT, NOW I FINALLY GOT
$100.
CAN YOU PLEASE TEACH ME HOW TO
PLAY THIS GAME.
>> ALL RIGHT, FIRST RULE IS --
AIN'T NOBODY JUMP IN THIS GAME.
>> YOU DID SAY THAT.
YOU DID SAY THAT.
>> I DID.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]